you is that each film has its own
identity and its own this is very
different than something than anything
else you guys have done ah that's what
we try and you know I believe that
that's the way we should do it because
that's how i feel about comics comics
can all be very diverse could all be
very different there was a character
there was another character that we
introduced
Tom Holland Tom Holland hey everyone yes
yes but a man whoa ladies and gentlemen
the director of spider-man homecoming
John watts hey John what we have we've
just started we've just started filming
this movie in Atlanta and it's amazing
to bring this character portrayed by
this guy into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it wouldn't be possible and
wouldn't have been possible without our
producing partner on this movie Amy
Pascal who's out there somewhere but she
is the reason that all of this happened
because she knew what was putting
everything else aside here's what's best
for the character here's what's best for
Spidey who everybody loves spider-man
yeah of course I mean it was it was such
it was such huge news in our world when
you guys were getting him back and to
find out that he was gonna be in civil
war and everyone's like oh how is this
gonna and then the second you came on
screen is like that's the guy he's the
guy so like how how is this portrayal of
spider-man different than what we've
seen and how are you guys tackling it
well first of all this it's a pretty
cool universe to be a part of right I
mean jeez um it's a high school movie
it's a straight up high school movie
it's about a 15 year old kid it's I
always describe it as this is the ground
level of the Marvel Universe you know we
know what it's like to be a billionaire
playboy inventor and we know what it's
like to be a alien god from another
dimension we're going to learn what it's
like to go to the astral plane and we're
also going to learn what it's like you
know to have just finished going through
puberty and be in 10th grade Thank an
bein Queens
ah did you bring some stuff today that
you could show everyone uh well would
you we just started shooting we should
actually be shooting right now probably
but we shot some of the height we shot
some of the high school stuff um so we
can show that all right we should yeah
good want to see it I want to see
anything probably right they literally
flew here today they're flying out
tonight we've been shooting for 10 days
but here's what we've been shooting no
recording even going you can see
anything yet have you set up whoa we got
some we got some of your other high
school students here if you want to
bring them out Laura Tony zendaya Jacob
come on out whoo
well guys so this is this is game like a
just kind of like a John Hughes II kind
of a spin is that does that accurate
yeah absolutely i mean it's just it's
man wouldn't you really want to tell
everyone that you were spider-man yeah
if you if you have to keep that secret
in high school man it would drive you
crazy yeah we really tried to just
capture sort of the spirit of those
movies and bring it into this crazy
universe yeah um how is it for how has
it been for you guys so far 10 days into
this really i mean is it sunk in what's
going on no right now it does everything
like this moment feels really fake I've
none of this is real but uh yeah it's
real it's an aerial real buddy accept
the love accept the love hazing is
amazing well thank you guys so much for
being here I know you guys I mean
literally anything work yeah you're
literally leaving right after this to go
back and continue shooting and then
hopefully we'll see some more stuff as
it rolls out but it'll be amazing and a
gank you everyone so goes and Tom
Holland thank you guys thanks you got
derrickson thank you have a fighter man
homecoming Tom home thank you all thank
you
so as you guys can see they didn't allow
anyone to post the actual teaser I'm
still gonna do a separate video that
will explain what that footage is it's
just like a really fun John Hughes movie
like they're talking about a day in the
life of Peter Parker as spider-man while
he's at high school so he has to find
like clever excuses to go away and do
spider-man things in the middle of the
day so that'll be my next video then
i'll do a doctor strange video there'll
be plenty more comic con stuff it's
probably going to take me through Monday
and Tuesday to get through everything so
just reminder that the Marvel giveaway
is still going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video is just a twenty dollar
amazon gift cards all announce the
winner when i post that spider-man
teaser breakdown why you guys wait for
that to post you can click up top here
for my flash season 3 trailer breakdown
and you can click down here for all my
Justice League wonder woman trailer
breakdowns thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
everybody you know high five from behind
the screen if you can't see my face
right now happy comic-con day for
comic-con is not over yet